fresh off of the monday night gridiron
last night
with another touchdown in his um
in his stat uh line last night for the
4-0 green bay packers aaron
jones back here on the show how you been
showtime
i've been good thank you thank you for
having me again no of course
you know how i feel about you and i just
love watching you succeed and as a
matter of fact i had that conversation
with aaron rodgers on this show just a
couple of weeks ago
and i mentioned your name to him and
he's got a front row seat
watching you run away from him and
watching you uh be targeted by him
uh and asked him what it's been like for
him he called you one of his best
favorite teammates since he's been a pro
aaron what did that mean to you
that meant a lot uh that's just special
to me um i mean you know
how many guys he's played with and how
many teammates he's had and
to feel that way about me and um i just
i just don't want to let him down come
in every day ready to work and continue
to grind
so uh he can keep that thought of me now
when you say you don't want to let him
down what is that dynamic
uh expound on that a little bit for me
if you don't mind aaron jones what do
you mean by that
i just want to be be a playmaker for him
um
any any ball throughout my way i want to
catch and help
help the offense any way i can and um so
whatever that whatever that means i just
want to be a playmaker and
um i think when when he sees your
playmaker and that you
you're ready to work and you want to
learn and listen and
um grow your game he's he's ready to
work with you
well i mean it seems that way you know i
could see him
at times last night um you know
uh given a a rah-rah attaboy to a lot of
people on the field
tanyan in particular um the way that he
shined out and i'm wondering if that is
your feeling about not wanting to let
aaron down and being a playmaker for him
is contagious on this team
oh yes sir it definitely is contagious
and uh bobby
kudos to bobby congrats to bobby because
he's been he's been working hard ever
since he's he's gotten here and um
he's been a playmaker i say until people
go cut on his
college film he's in a lot of
one-on-ones just making plays catching
balls and
um so he he's done the same thing came
in um
more no work wanted to learn one to grow
and elevate his game and
aaron aaron seeing that in him as well
and he takes guys like that under his
wing and he he uh
helps us grow as players and another
thing that you have a front row seat for
you had last night i want to ask you
because i overheard it i heard it
aaron rodgers got the falcons jumping
offsides
using a hard count but using the words
hard count as his heart count that
happened last night
right aaron yes sir i mean i didn't hear
exactly what he said i was just watching
the ball so i made sure i didn't jump
[Laughter]
are you serious like it's difficult for
you guys not to jump when he hard counts
even though you probably know it's
coming
oh it definitely is i mean his voice
sounds so
all of all of his cadences so if he's
going on three
um his first set hut will sound the same
as the second set as the third and
so you gotta really sit in there and
lock in and
he could tell you in the huddle it's on
three and you get to the line and his
voice just sells it so much
you'd be convinced this one won so you
really just got to lock in
so essentially what you're saying aaron
jones is that you know
from the man himself from his own mouth
what
the snap is going to be on three
and that his heart count is so good it
makes you second guess whether you
heard it right in the huddle is that
what you're saying
yes sir definitely definitely
that is amazing that is truly again
remarkable and so again is your is your
team um 17 out of 20 since the head
coach has come in what has matt laflore
done for you
with you that you that you can tell me
about aaron jones
uh he's came in and he's really opened
up the offense for
me and not only me but uh the rest of
the backs and uh just giving us a chance
to
make plays in in the receiving game and
the passing game
uh be a versatile part of the offense
and use us in many different ways
so coach lafleur does a great job of
scheming things
up and getting guys open as well and i
uh i love playing for him and
appreciate everything he's done for me
aaron jones here on the rich eisen show
okay
we've reached the health and safety part
of this first you
uh and i asked this on behalf of all
fantasy owners of of aaron jones
including my 12 year old son xander
who got uh genuinely concerned in the
second quarter last night when
there were not a lot of snaps for you
aaron is everything okay what happened
last night how are you personally
feeling aaron jones oh i'm feeling good
everything was okay uh they just said
they were gonna start
off the series with somebody else and um
that was it and
you know just waiting for my number to
be called again okay well i got a lot of
dad points last night when i said i will
ask aaron jones
himself tomorrow uh zan you know that's
a god that's a good dad point thing
for me so i appreciate that but honestly
when my son looks at me
and he says to me dad how's aaron jones
doing um
i like that it's kind of cool i'll take
it that is pretty cool
i said what's up i will do that more dad
points he's handing out dad points to me
aaron jones here uh and then uh health
and safety you're on a bye week now
and this is the concerning aspect about
uh the pandemic and covet 19 that
uh the entire league had been uh
concerned
uh about this year is what happens in a
bye week
so what where are you going where are
your teammates going to be
what is this bye week for you going to
be about on that health and safety front
what can you tell me
aaron uh we're not allowed to leave town
so
all of my teammates and me will be
staying here in town okay
i'll be at home he'll come in tomorrow
what's tomorrow
wednesday coming tomorrow and after
tomorrow we'll have thursday friday
saturday off
sunday as well and um but the facility
will still be open and
so i'll probably just relax at home my
some of my family in town so relax with
them and
come and get some work out in it and uh
eat some free food
if it's free it's me so nicely done kind
of
still in your first contract you're
hanging out a little bit still on your
first contract are you aaron is that
basically
yeah sir still there just free is me
i'll take it
okay but uh so you will not be in
the rest of your teammates um who are uh
not required i guess due to
whatever injuries are banged up you you
are free to
be away from the facility thursday
through sunday or do you have to come in
and get tested every day still
oh we definitely have to come in and get
covert tested still every day
so you're still going to be tested that
part out oh yeah
okay well it's a crucial part i mean you
know where i'm driving at here and what
i'm doing biggest part
you know what i'm aiming at so what what
did uh because again uh anybody who's
who's paying attention to this
knows that uh covert 19 is spiking
in green bay specifically right now it's
the hospitals in green bay need help
they need they need people to also
uh mask up and and treat this virus
seriously what what has your coach told
you what what
is what what was the i guess message
after the win last night on this front
aaron
uh his message was just be smart about
everything you do you know
like you said uh green bay is the hot
spot number one hot spot here
like you said the hospitals are 100
capacity
um so just be careful what you do it
like when you're going to the
gas station if you're pumping gas put on
some gloves or half hand sanitizer
um keep your hands out of your face in
your mouth really kind of just stay at
home um
and you want some food order it or
come to the facility those kind of
things and you know you
then he also reminds us that all of us
have families at home that we have to go
to
and one person makes a bad decision
and it could affect everybody else and
their family members as well so to just
keep keep your teammates and your
brothers in mind as well
okay aaron well i'm keeping you in mind
as well i just love watching you do what
you do
um and you keep doing it it's it's just
really great to see
and um every packer fan that watches you
uh puts so much hope into you and uh if
i may the other aaron
uh it means a lot you mean a lot to a
lot of people so just keep doing what
you do
oh yes sir thank you that means a lot
thank you you got it you take care of
yourself and
you know i like our regular chats i
think it's like once every three weeks
now this is great
me too i think we need to make it a
thing i i'm enjoying it
me too right back at you you take care
of yourself aaron jones
yes sir thank you that's aaron jones
right here in the ritual show
good people hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that
watch more right here